time now for our seen and unseen segment
where we expose what's really behind the
big cultural stories of the day
CNN may have to issue a major attraction
after they charge Morgan Freeman with
sexual harassment and would you pay more
than a thousand dollars for a t-shirt no
here to explain it all New York Times
bestselling author of The Wheel Wilder
series and Fox News contributor Raymond
Arroyo Raymond first thing is this
Morgan Freeman deal I mean he's a
renowned actor a DAT play God an Academy
Award winner Driving Miss Daisy what
album Chloe MELAS is a CNN reporter she
wrote a piece exposing charging Morgan
Freeman with sexual harassment she
claims she was on a junket interviewing
Friedman and in the middle of the
interview he looked over and said oh I
wish I were there and looked toward her
she was pregnant at the time she took
that as sexual harassment he claims he
was talking to Michael Kane who had just
said he was going to some locale and
Friedman said I wish I were there here's
the problem with this entire report if
somebody is the the charger the one
who's claiming these making these
accusations why are they allowed to
write the piece by CNN this was also
investigated by Time Warner movement
which does you know is exposing some you
know real abuses right but this is our
v1 it's someone like you're looking at
me every year it's like my kids like
Marie is looking at me stop her look at
me it's like you don't even say boy
likes ten years later inappropriate hugs
I mean all those inappropriate stories
here's the problem Freeman is now saying
it through his lawyer
this is defamation he made a list there
are some who believe he really has a
case here and in this age when you have
a black celebrity like this at this
level I think CNN is all right
Roseanne now this is a ter headline from
the New York Times
Roxanne Greg it gave colonists the
problem is that Donald Trump is a toxic
president who amassed his power through
provocation of hate the problem is that
having a major character in a prominent
TV show as a trump supporter normalizes
racism and misogyny and of course throw
it in for good measure
the phobia so having a character Raymond
Arroyo
on a show who supports Trump is racism
misogyny we are seeing blanket racism
being thrown around as a charge and
columnist hsihu confuse Roseanne Barr
the actor with Roseanne Connor the
character she plays on TV here's the
here's the bottom line for me on this
Roseanne story Roseanne
did its job you know what it did it
awakened the entertainment community but
there was middle America that was
underserved and they were looking for
someone to be their voice it's not like
them it doesn't have to be Roseanne
we're gonna see it in Last Man Standing
and you'll see it in other characters
watch there are more stories too much
money to be made in giving voice to at
least someone who's not demonized every
five seconds because they subpoena after
this point they're still demonizing and
those shows will still be there still
demonizing the Trump supporters as the
deplorable troglodyte xenophobes etc
lame rod brush now Jesse Duplantis I
have never heard of this person he's a
famous tel Aviv I neck of the woods from
Louisiana well he up to the Lord has
called him to have a fourth private jet
he already has three and here's his
explanation for this calling now people
say my lord can't you go with this way
yes but I can't go at one stop and you
see if I can do it with one stop I can
fly it for a lot cheaper because I have
my own fuel phone I really believe that
if Jesus was physically on the earth
today it wouldn't be riding a donkey
when the Lord said store up your riches
in heaven I don't think this is what he
had in mind this guy's asking 54 million
dollars from his followers for another
1/4 private jet is it a G for God
forgets a Falcon God for Falcon 7 Falcon
oh that's a nice plan well he's not the
only one free flow dollar and this
fellow Kenneth Copeland also have
private planes and they're on TV
defending why they need private planes
to spread the guts that thing about
getting a rich person and through the
camel apparently has two jet engines
what the world is in such a shape we
can't get there without this nice we've
got to have this I would have to stop
I'm being very conservative at least
said
five to eighty more like ninety percent
of what we're doing cuz you can't get
there from here it's impossible they
don't like commercial airlines because
too many people on you they say it's
like Salmons in a tube I got rather
demons in a tube on a commercial flight
than snakes on a private plane I'll
leave it there
we'll talk t-shirts next time all right
now t-shirt t-shirt you want to talk
about this a 1290 dollar t-shirt shirt
has been released this is it
well I can spend $1,000 to essentially
look like a laundry rack it's a
button-up shirt sewn onto your t-shirt
or you can wear it interchangeably and
have a tee now that it looks like you
walked out of your house with static
cling looks terrible is that homeless
chic oh yeah I don't know what it is I'm
not buying I would like a private plane
sister Ingram nope racks it oh yeah
that's all a little toy one that knows
about my own ministry over here